une vingtaine de familles sans logis ont
passé leur première nuit dans un
immeuble de la cogedim rue du dragon à
saint germain des prés dans le centre de
la capitale à paris un immeuble voué à
la destruction mais dont le premier
ministre a assuré que les squatteurs ne
seraient pas délogés c'est du moins ce
qu'il a promis à l'abbé pierre qui avait
aidé ces squatters à investir les lieux
ambiance ce matin sur place avec nos
reporters antoine cormery pascal qu'à
un biberon ou un café chaud et la
lecture des journaux du matin redonne du
courage à ceux qui viennent de passer
leur première nuit au 7 rue du dragon
une nuit sans chauffage et sans
électricité qui venait couronner la plus
grosse opération coup de poing menée par
l'association du droit au logement
on a fait quelque chose qui apparaît
c'est appréciable ouvrir un immeuble
aussi grand que celui là il mettre des
familles
et puis nous allons voir le premier
ministre quelqu'un qui a en charge la
france qui est le dit bien sûr je suis
pas d'accord avec les actions illégales
mais je vous promets de ne pas faire
intervenir les forces de l'homme autre
bout et on ne vous demandera partir que
quand on aura trouvé un logement pour
tout le monde 120 personnes en attente
de logement est prête à payer un loyer
modique n'ont donc trouver d'autres
solutions que d'enfreindre le sacro
saint droit de propriété au mois
d'octobre je me suis retrouvé avec un
licenciement abusif c'est mon patron qui
me faisait sous location d'un
appartement sans quittance en bail et
donc de ce fait je me suis retrouvé à la
rue et donc ça que je suis si
les dix mille mètres carrés de
l'immeuble était voué à la démolition
par la cogedim et la crise de
l'immobilier a gelé le projet est depuis
plus de deux ans tous les logements
étaient vides quant aux démêlés
judiciaires actuel de la cogedim sur
d'autres dossiers il en faisait aussi
une cible idéale on souhaite qu'ils
aient la démarche d'edf et de la banque
de france c'est à dire que au nom d'une
certaine solidarité ils puissent dès
aujourd'hui dire qu'ils mettent à
disposition des familles dans leur
logement cet immeuble je crois que ce
serait une solution
mon qui me paraît pas leur demander
beaucoup mais l'opération très
médiatique a aussi une vocation
politique celle de squatter la campagne
présidentielle